is the great future hall of famer future
first ballot hall of famer top five
all-time quarterback in nfl history in
my opinion drew brees drew great to see
you you too how do you deal with like
okay like idiots like me okay who are
like me trust questions it's not easy
but like you know hey listen you know i
i question where you're at in your
career sometimes and things like that
like how do you block out noise you know
i mean it's my job i hope you always
know i have great respect for you and
things like that but how do you how do
you deal with that i i'm really
interested in your mindset there
well do you block it out or do you read
stuff no i don't i don't i don't read
any of it you don't listen to any of it
i don't believe any of it yeah i do hear
it right um because it really doesn't
matter i mean for me i i am already
fueled and motivated enough right you
are i mean i got that i got the list i
got the chip on my shoulder always will
yeah i i'm always out to prove something
right and i it's just the way i'm wired
yeah um i feel like maybe that's the way
i've had to approach my whole career
from the very beginning yeah true um but
listen man i i love i love what i do i
love the game and so
um
you know the the preparation and the
grind and all those things those are
things you kind of look forward to you
know i mean here we are the season's
still somewhat fresh i mean it's not
even over yet right we still have the
super bowl to be played but um we were
just talking about a little bit like i'm
in this dad mode a little bit now daddy
daycare he said getting back from
getting back into the house you know
trying not to throw off mom's routine
you're right right you know coaching
ball and doing all that stuff right it's
great i mean you need that time like i'm
i'm gonna be away from football here for
a bit just relaxing and spending time
with family we're gonna have plenty more
with drew brees here from miami when pft
live continues right after this
there he is drew brees future hall of
famer and long time member of the new
orleans saints it's amazing how many
people forget you actually played for
the charters
yes he played for the chargers
chargers for five years five years and
saints for
14. just finished 14. my god i saw it in
action in in san diego i was a backup
for the bucks one year 2004.
right before you and ladanian just diced
us up i was like whoa they're another
level you know what i want to ask you do
you know how many ticks you have on the
field
like
you are the tick king oh you're talking
about the bug no no he's not the dick
you're the one with the bug okay coffin
over here but you with the uh no i'm
adjusting the pads i'm licking the
fingers and shoulder shake i got you
down i got you down you're unbelievable
here's the thing i feel like it's gotten
worse
and i
i'd say like within the last four or
five years i've really started to
recognize it like god why do i do that
so much i don't even realize i'm doing
it right but yeah i've just got all
these crazy ticks yeah yo there's a few
quarterbacks that do like rogers has a
shoulder shimmy he does every time you
know payton used to like always do like
you know this and like pull up his ipad
so i'm like crazy like that and i look
at it all right i gotta kick you got all
these down i gotta i do it on social
media every now and then i do i do
impersonations prescott just told you
the other day that that the the dak
dance is is an offshoot of of what he's
learned from watching you oh did that
did uh
he said it's all you i mean dak prescott
jake fromm from georgia yesterday i
talked to them they all when people talk
about mechanics and doing those things
they always talk about you
and where where do you get it from who
teaches you where do you how do you stay
on top of yourself you guys would
probably hear the name tom house sure
right so shaun house is one of my great
mentors a guy who i've worked with for
shoot 15 years now right or longer and
uh i seek his advice and wisdom and
tutelage every offseason we get together
and spend a lot of time together and i
think at this stage in my career too um
mechanics becomes so important right
because i i can't afford to waste an
ounce of anything right i've got to
maximize i got a max mine's gotta be so
efficient and so
um i do pay a lot of attention mechanics
and i do a lot of stuff just to get the
body warmed up sure involves a lot of
those movements right that go into
throwing a football right yeah you know
we have seen plenty of quarterbacks over
the years who when they get closer and
closer to the natural end
they they talk openly about retirement
because you know we look at it
skeptically and say they just want a
little attention they're really not
going to retire they just want to talk
about it and they want people to talk
about it they want people to beg them to
play i feel like with you that's not the
case you're not that's not your game
that's not what you're doing you are
seriously seriously thinking about
whether or not to come back next year
yeah
and and i told listen i've had a process
you know each and every off-season um
i mean listen let's go back to
2014-1516
with the saints you know those were
tough years right um and to give a
little history there there was kind of a
shift shift with our team our locker
room after the 13th season you know we
had four out of five years going to the
playoffs really making a run at it and
we lost a ton of veteran leadership on
the on on that after that 13 season so
you know i felt like there was a shift i
think in our locker room and a lot of
things and 14 15 16 were tough years to
the point where
you know we weren't we weren't
having successful seasons we weren't
going to the playoffs and i thought you
know what maybe maybe it's time at this
point that i walk away you know maybe
this game has passed me by maybe maybe
it's time and so i went into the 17
season saying you know what this is
probably going to be this might be my
last year if we have another year like
we just had then this may be my last
year and man things shifted um we had a
great locker room we had a great year
and i could see i could see
us kind of rebuilding the foundation of
the culture by which i knew we could be
successful but it was also at that
moment where i just said listen i'm
going to play each year one year at a
time like one year because each year may
be my last and i truly want to enjoy it
as much as i can and i i've had more fun
playing football the last three years
than i've ever had and arguably been
able to play some of my best football at
the same time too and i've had a ton ton
of success as a team
so i've just taken that approach and i
don't i don't want to take it for
granted i also don't want to just kind
of jump to conclusions so man this
season ends and it's like all right i'm
going to take a deep breath here i'm
going to
um just enjoy some time with my family
and i'm not going to make any decisions
i'm going to give it a little while here
and let everybody know where i'm at in a
few weeks yeah good for you you should
you i mean you you certainly deserve to
do that man i mean it's been awesome to
watch and like i'm always fascinated by
you and like sean payton just the
combination like for you what is it that
makes sean
amazing because he talked about you the
other day like what is the one thing
where you just go this is why he is sean
payton
uh you're both psychos so that fits yeah
right
sean sean has a great way of uh
taking all the noise and all the
distraction and all the stuff that's
happening
outside the building and maybe even
inside the building at times and just
narrowing it down to a very singular
focus right like guys this is what it's
going to take to win this game right and
this is this these are the positions i'm
going to put you in to do it right i
think he's he's a great teacher yeah um
he
he he has he has a gr you know he spent
a lot of time with parcells right and so
there's a lot of
parcelisms you know in psychology in the
way that he coaches right and yet i
think he does it at times in a humorous
way a fun way maybe a little bit more of
the new age yeah right than the old
school
and yet it's it's
that part's in him as well you know so i
think he's a great blend of both he's a
tough but fair coach always open door
policy yeah if you want to know where
you stand on the team you can go knock
on sean payton's door and he will be
honest with you and he will tell you
yeah um
and he's he's highly competitive he's
highly aggressive yeah you know as a
play caller and just as an offensive
mind
and
uh
it makes a lot of fun for for a
quarterback yeah sure high level of
expectation right but we work well
together yeah has he given you
that same kind of direct message and
understanding of what 2020 would be like
if you choose to come back because it's
hard not to feel that they want to use
taysom hill more the impact he had in
the playoff game he was incredible but
there's only one guy that can take the
snap and i feel like at some level they
maybe want to use him more but i
definitely believe they want you to come
back but have you gotten an impression
from sean on on what the division of
labor would be if you're there and take
some hills yeah
no we we we haven't we haven't gotten
that far um
but i'll be the first one to sit here
and tell you that
if if i'm back and and taysom's there
alongside me
call the plays that are going to put us
in the best position to win right if
that means taysom hill is taking 30
snaps a game
25 snaps a game then so be it i'm all
for that number one because i i know
what type of player he is i know the
impact he can have right and i think
that you gave the example of the vikings
game it was unbelievable the guy pretty
much took the game over right right
right um
he's he's blocking a power play and then
he's throwing a touch you know darn near
throwing a touchdown on the next play
and then catching one here at some it's
it's unreal
what he can do there's nobody like him
he's a unicorn but um
he's a great guy too guys on the team
love them um and so listen whatever it
takes to win but if that means sharon
snaps to take some health and so be it
and i know he wants you to come back i
mean you would think he's thinking hey
it's my time i'm ready to step onto the
stage give me the ball i know he wants
you to come back he's a taste facing
yeah he's one of my best friends yeah
yeah yeah it's cool so we've got a great
relationship
you like and i'm we're going to hit
smoothie king here in a minute because
that you're i want a protein shake okay
but like either way
i want to know like do you feel like a
little cursed over the last few years i
mean it's just absolutely amazing i mean
whether it's the minneapolis miracle the
debacle in the championship game and
then this year another curse where you
were guys weren't even on the field i
mean that was past interference by the
49ers and then and then or the push off
you were on the field today you had two
like crazy things happen because you
could have very easily had that first
round bye i mean how do you digest that
um
well
you can only worry about the things you
can control yeah see that's why you're
drew brees i'd be like still pulling my
hair out that's why i'm not that's why
i'm sitting over here i mean listen
there there were there were things i
mean you could look at all those games
but but especially the last two yeah
there's there's things that happen in
those games prior to that
that that had we had we done a little
bit better you know it never would have
right you know ended up with that right
now it's still very unfortunate yeah
right it's very unfortunate but uh we
don't control that did you did you like
when the pit out of your stomach leave
after last year's nfc championship game
like i only played one playoff game in
my life and it took me like three weeks
no you're still not over it you're still
not right
i feel like we're the better team and
i'm sure you felt like that way last
year too when did it finally like you
finally get over those redskins game one
you're right
i remember it yeah yeah it's crazy the
recall right i know all right um
no i uh i was it was by far the worst
loss of my career right
in the way that i felt after because
there's such a finality to it yeah you
know something like that happens during
the season and it's it's man on the next
march
but man it's like just
right now it's done it's over and
especially with the expectation level of
where we're going and what we felt like
we could accomplish um so yeah that was
that was crushing yeah i know crushing
all right come on pitch man let me hear
it
let's do it
where's the uh do you want the high
protein coffee almond mocha smoothie or
would you like the uh immune builder ooh
you're working some long day oh that's
right i have no splash right
right yes sorry i remember that one too
yeah i know i was so disappointed in
2006 because you came to the saints and
i was a starter in tampa and got hurt
that year and i was looking so forward
to oh my gosh i'm gonna play against
drew brees and all these things and uh
yeah it didn't happen but yeah i want
the immune builders
the mutant builder yeah no so the
smoothie king's part part of my uh my
season and off season routine i love
taking the boys there but um fitness
plenty of fitness and wellness blends
it's they've been a great partner too um
with some of our youth sports programs
and our foundation so
smoothie king's a great been a great
partner yeah yeah
chris is doing his best to get his own
sponsors he he is going over the top
with i'm not pitching yes he is i mean i
go over the top because like smoothie
king probably gave him a lot of money
and i just want to give them
is your pitch going to be i
uh chris sims here i don't have a spleen
but smoothie king keeps me keeping me
healthy from getting sick i'm getting
herpes on my lips oh my god here we go
hey drew
who you like in the game are you liking
the game um
man this is tough um well i didn't play
the chiefs we played the niners um i
think the niners are
one of the most complete teams out there
um but i love the playmaking ability of
patrick mahomes offense so um i don't
know i just want a high scoring game
yeah you you the niners who was the guy
that like we've had a lot of players go
like oh boss is the guy but who was the
guy like you were
game planning for them where you were
just like holy cow is he disruptive he's
unbelievable
well
both as a stud but their whole front
four and then they got they got
substitutes that are coming in right and
getting sacked right so i just returned
on the film getting ready for the guy
these guys just like i mean usually you
have one or two guys which like all
right we're gonna chip here we're gonna
double team here we're gonna do this and
you're just like
just get the ball out here right what
i'm saying
yeah they they got a bunch of studs you
tore them up man i mean that was their
worst performance of the year really you
and your all go special touchdowns and
all that
so 49ers are chiefs i missed it who you
got who you got
um
i want i want uh i want andy reid to get
a ring yeah i'm gonna go chiefs yeah i
hear you that's good that's good sean
did a great job of just completely
avoiding the questions
color rush uniforms yeah oh i mean he
just he did everything he could here's
the thing we're gonna play with both
these teams next year uh the saints so
oh yeah right i don't wanna i don't
wanna i don't know
we wish you the best whatever you decide
drew you you'll make the right decision
for you and your family and we we have a
feeling we're going to see you one way
or the other either with a helmet on or
with a helmet off drew brees isn't going
anywhere but if it brings you back to
the football field we would love to see
another year of drew brees with the new
orleans saints that's for damn sure yeah
thank you mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports